caught up with partnered attorney
matthew hoffman at battle board injury
lawyers out of las vegas to get reaction
to president biden's vaccination
requirement
this is very aggressive matt widespread
for some 100 million employees
yeah it is it's it's extremely
aggressive it's a strong stance
um
i think that this is
what we're going to see
in response to the fda full approval of
the pfizer vaccine because now there's
no excuses at this point it's fda
approved just like any other vaccine
that we've all taken as kids is a you
know in order to go to school in order
to go to college
and because of that they're going to
enforce this and try to end this
some people can be terminated from their
jobs if they don't follow these these
orders this mandate correct
yeah that's absolutely correct and um
when you're talking about the safety and
welfare of the public
the governments on all levels have
vast broad authority
to do vaccine mandates any kind of
safety mandates and that's why you're
seeing this mandated through medicare
medicaid you're seeing it mandated
through osha
this executive order then paves the way
for our school district certainly the
fifth largest in the nation then to move
forward with this without any legal
pushback or other from staff parents
educators department of education
correct
yes and no
the fda full approval is for 16 and up
so it's the age of 16 and up and that
that includes employees
and then students that are 16 and over
absolutely they can be mandated to do it
there's really no argument around it
other than religious exemptions or
medical
exemptions and religious exemptions are
really hard to prove
medical exemptions are not but they're
obviously rare